this is kind of funny but also sad uh
one of the many sham
claims that the supporters of donald
trump have made
about the 2020 election is that dead
people
voted now as more and more of these
claims are investigated more and more of
these claims are being debunked i'm
going to have a voicemail for you
about dead people voting but this might
come as a shock to some of you
in a country of 331 million people there
are lots of people with the same name
even people with the same middle initial
and when you hear that
you know 118 year old joe smith voted
but joe smith died 20 years ago it might
actually be 72 year old
joe smith that voted from the same city
there's this really funny thing so when
i lived in when i lived in new york city
i was in a band
one of my band mates i'm not going to
give his real name so people don't go
doxing him but i'm going to give you a
name that will work um his first name
uh is eddie now eddie typically
would be edward but sometimes eddie is
short for
or a nickname for edwin so my bandmate's
name
was uh eddie a
jimenez okay let's go let's say that
eddie a jimenez
and he once looked up how many
eddie a jimenez's are there
in new york city and there's a whole
bunch okay but then he said here's what
here's more a more interesting question
how many
edwin a jimenez's are there in new york
city edwin being
much less common and there were 11.
so even a name like edwin a jimenez
that's not the actual name i'm just
you know modifying it so that you people
don't go and try to figure out who this
guy is
there were 11 people with the same
middle initial even edwin a jimenez in
new york city
so a lot of that is what's going on with
these so-called dead voters so the trump
campaign has been alleging dead voters
for a while
one such example is that trump's
campaign
and fox news host tucker carlson last
week alleged that a georgia woman
named deborah jean christensen voted
while dead
the campaign in carlson said it was
fraud
deborah jean christensen died last year
now in fact the vote was legally cast
by a living woman whose name is also
deborah jean christensen born in the
same year
and the same month but on a different
day now cnn eventually interviewed her
they went to her door she was alive she
was a real person who was alive and
voting
there's another example which is the
case of mr and mrs
james blaylock now mr james blaylock
did pass away years ago his wife
votes under the name mrs james blaylock
here she is alive and well take a look
he's not voted he didn't vote
it was you it was me president of the
united states was accusing you of voter
fraud
essentially oh i know it and and i knew
it wasn't fraud
who did you vote for you don't have to
share that
i voted for the democrats for buying
i think i guess i voted against the
other one really
so there it is dead voters who were
actually
alive now i've also been accused of
being dead before do you guys remember
this is it's sort of an aside but
years ago there was a documentary uh a
perfectly reasonable documentary
about uh gay teens who were
bullied so ferociously in school
that they took their own lives and
that's a real thing that's a very very
sad thing
but for some reason we've not been able
to figure out i was in the montage in a
sort of in memoriam
of uh bullied uh gay teens who died by
suicide
and at the time this came as a shock to
a lot of people in the audience now at
the time
i was not a teen i was 27 years old at
the time
i was not gay and i was not bullied and
i also wasn't dead which was important
to clarify and i issued a clarification
so i understand
uh what it's like to be accused of being
dead when you're when you were actually
alive
so this is all completely wacky the
trump campaign
is making all sorts of accusations of
dead people voting
tucker carlson ended up apologizing for
one false claim about a dead person
voting
now even if anecdotally some of these
supposedly
dead voters are either still alive or
didn't vote
it's still worth i i think doing a more
thorough investigation of this and
that's what the bbc did the bbc
looked at the claim that was made by the
trump campaign
or people around trump that 10 000 dead
dead people voted in michigan that's the
that's the top line number 10 000 dead
people voted in michigan
now as a reminder the margin in michigan
by which joe biden won
is about 46 000 so to start with
they're claiming 10 000 dead people
voted in michigan
even if those were all biden votes it
would not reverse the results but
bbc started with 10 000 good then
the bbc picked 31 names from the list of
dead voters
and said let's research these 31
supposedly dead voters
11 of the 31 were alive they'd call them
up people they said nope i'm alive no
problem no
no big deal so about one third of the
sample of supposedly dead voters were
people who were just alive
17 of the 31 supposedly dead voters
they've researched and found no reason
to believe that
they were dead in other words for 17 of
the 31 people about half of the sample
trumpists are claiming these people are
dead
they found no death notices no
obituaries in many cases they found you
know online profiles of people who are
still alive and and
you know posting things online there was
no reason to think 17 of the 31 person
sample
was dead and then they found three
people
of the 31 who actually are dead but
listen to this
in two of the three cases where dead
people
supposedly voted it was these situations
of a father and a son with the same name
and indeed ballots were requested and
returned
under the father's name but it was a
clerical error in other words
the son voted it was registered as a
vote
by the father but there was not actually
a vote registered by the son so
it's not even a double vote like yes
it's a clerical error
but it was a son voting under his
father's name
one time no double voting there either
so as you can see
taking a random 31 person sample from
the supposedly 10 000 dead voters
uh very very quickly falls apart it's
important to do this it's important to
understand
the reality now let's go to the
voicemail which is related to this
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people
quit smoking and vaping by offering a
clean
affordable nicotine alternative now
many of you know you've heard the
stories i've known several people in my
life who have struggled with quitting
smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical